[Musik]
sehr geehrte Angehörige des
österreichischen Bundesheers ich habe
bei meinen vielen Truppen besuchen
zuletzt war ich etwa beim
Pionierbataillon 3 in Melk einen guten
Eindruck ihrer Arbeit und vor allem
ihres Könnens gewonnen ihre hohe
Motivation und ihre ausgezeichneten
Fachkenntnisse von denen ich mich in
meinen Gesprächen mit Soldatinnen und
Soldaten überzeugen konnte haben mich
immer wieder beeindruckt
ich möchte die Gelegenheit heute nutzen
allen Soldatinnen und Soldaten für ihren
täglichen Einsatz zu danken besonders
jenen die derzeit in Krisengebieten im
Ausland und im Assistenzeinsatz im
Inland ihren Dienst versehen sie haben
sich Respekt und Anerkennung für ihre
gewissenhafte Pflichterfüllung und
professionelle Leistungen erworben und
das sowohl auf nationaler wie auch auf
internationaler Ebene
und dazu braucht es auch bei Ihnen meine
Damen und Herren vom Bundesheer in
meinen Augen die folgenden Eigenschaften
Mut
Mut im Sinne des Vertrauens in die
eigene Kraft
Tapferkeit
Tapferkeit auch im Sinne von
Zivilcourage
und Disziplin
Disziplin im Sinne einer wertbewussten
inneren Haltung die sich im eigenen Tun
materialisiert
sie wurden in ihrer Ausbildung auch
darauf vorbereitet und die besonderen
psychischen und physischen Belastungen
handlungsfähig zu bleiben
seien sie sich der besonderen
Verantwortung bewusst die sie als
Führungspersönlichkeit bei Einsätzen im
In- und Ausland für die ihnen
anvertrauten Soldatinnen und Soldaten
tragen
meine Damen und Herren
sie werden in den unterschiedlichsten
Funktionen Verantwortung übernehmen und
sowohl national als auch international
dazu beitragen Frieden und Sicherheit in
unserer Heimat und in Europa zu schaffen
sie bekennen sich zu den demokratischen
Werten und sie haben gelernt als
Offiziere stets den Mittel den Menschen
in den Mittelpunkt ihres Denkens und
Handelns zu stellen ich möchte Ihnen
dafür danken dass sie als
Berufsoffiziere unsere Republik dienen
in gleicher Weise danke ich auch den
Leuten an das milizsstandes die bereit
sind neben ihrem zivilen Beruf
freiwillig sehr viel Zeit zu investieren
um als Offiziere zum Schutz der
österreichischen Bevölkerung beizutragen
ein Wort des Dankes und vielleicht noch
deutlicher wenn es mit einer
symbolischen Gäste verbunden ist es ist
mir eine große Ehre den von mir
gestifteten Ehren Säbel dem Jahrgangs
ersten stellvertretend für den gesamten
ausmusterungsjahrgang zu überreichen in
diesem Sinne wünsche ich Ihnen allen
alles Gute und viel Erfolg in ihrem
Beruf es lebe das österreichische
Bundesheer das lebe unsere Heimat die
Republik Österreich es lebe unser
gemeinsames Europa
das ist mir eine große Freude und Ehre
Ihnen als kleines Zeichen der
Anerkennung für ihre ausgezeichneten
Leistungen diesen Säbel zu überreichen
der Bundespräsident ich bedanke mich für
diese hohe Auszeichnung als auch für das
Vertrauen der Republik und fühle mich
geehrt diesen Hebel entgegennehmen zu
dürfen gerne alles Gute alles Gute und
viel Erfolg in ihrem künftigen Beruf
[Applaus]
es ist wahrlich ein großer Tag heute ein
großer Tag für sie ein großer Tag für
die jungen ihr angetretenen Damen und
Herren leutnende in ihrer Karriere als
Offizier ein großer Tag aber auch für
das Bundesheer und ein großer Tag für
die Republik Österreich
denn heute werden sie also Offiziere in
das österreichische Bundesheer
übernommen mit ihnen steht hier die
nächste Generation die für die
Sicherheit für die Sicherheit unserer
Bevölkerung für die Sicherheit von uns
allen sorgen wird
die ureigenste Aufgabe ist die
militärische Landesverteidigung wir
dürfen aber auch andere Bedrohungen
nicht aus dem Auge verlieren wie die in
den vergangenen Jahren erlebte Pandemie
selber Angriffe Terrorismus Blackouts
und Naturkatastrophen das heißt dass die
Gewährleistung der Sicherheit im Inneren
im Rahmen eines sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatzes zum Beispiel zum
schutzkritischer Infrastruktur
notversorgungseinrichtungen sowie zum
Schutz und zur Unterstützung der
Bevölkerung eine besondere Aufgabe
darstellt das Bundesheer als die
strategische Reserve der Republik
Österreich wir müssen vorbereitet sein
auf alle Eventualitäten wir sind durch
unseren Grundauftrag darauf ausgerichtet
auch dann noch zu funktionieren wenn
sonst nichts mehr funktioniert
sehr geehrte Offiziere Ausbildner Lehrer
der Militärakademie und von anderen
Dienststellen unseres Bundesheeres es
ist mir ein Bedürfnis ihnen zu danken
für ihre Arbeit für ihre Mühe die sie in
die Ausbildung der Veränderung in all
den Jahren gesteckt haben jetzt sind die
jungen Soldatinnen und Soldaten zu
leugnen geworden bin überzeugt davon
dass sie immer wieder zurückkommen in
diese ihre akademische Heimat und dass
sie vieles dass sie während der
Ausbildung erlebt haben auch im
Gedächtnis behalten werden sehr geehrte
Leuten und dem Miliz und Berufsoffiziere
ich gratuliere Ihnen zur erfolgreichen
Absolvierung der Offiziersausbildung der
damit verbundenen Beförderung zum
Leutnant sie mussten in eine Zeit aus
die wie schon angesprochen von der
gesamten Sicherheitslage ausgesehen mit
Sicherheit nicht einfacher wird wir
müssen uns auf diese zukünftigen
Herausforderungen einstellen sie sind
bestens dafür ausgebildet das ist ein
neuer Abschnitt in ihrer militärischen
Laufbahn neue Zeiten dazu wünsche ich
wünschen wir Ihnen alles erdenklich Gute
für die Zukunft viel Erfolg und
natürlich das notwendige Soldaten Glück
es lebe der Jahrgang freier Lenk von
Wolfsberg es lebe die Theresianische
Militärakademie es lebe das
österreichische Bundesheer es lebe die
Republik Österreich
[Applaus]
es ist ein Tag der Freude und eine
gewisser Tag der Genugtuung auch für
mich wenn ich in die Runde hier Blicke
und sich der maretessen Platz
wieder füllt
und zwar mit zunehmend mehr
militärkademikerinnen und mit
militärakademikern mit leitnernden mit
Katheten mit Schülern
das ist ein gutes Zeichen
und sie insbesondere
werden mit dem heutigen Tag in die
Streitkräfte des österreichischen
Bundesheeres integriert die
Berufssoldaten insbesondere aber die
Milizsoldaten natürlich auch auf neuen
Positionen
und daher gratuliere ich Ihnen dass Sie
die
herausforderte Ausbildung so erfolgreich
wie wir es gestern gehört haben
absolviert haben das ist ein ganz ein
positives Zeichen
und ich danke
der Theresianischen Militärakademie und
damit auch dem österreichischen
Bundesheer das alles mögliche investiert
wurde um Ihnen eine adäquate Ausbildung
zu geben damit sie in ihrem Berufsfeld
bestehen können
ich bedanke mich aber auch bei den
Angehörigen dieser jungen Damen und
Herren Leuten an die hier vor uns stehen
weil sie es mitgetragen haben und in
vielen Bereichen sogar erst ermöglicht
haben dass wir heute
über 100
Berufsoffiziere und milizoffiziere vor
uns stehen haben
ich möchte Ihnen noch etwas mitgeben sie
haben es gestern auch bereits erfahren
heutzutage ist lebenslanges Lernen eine
Selbstverständlichkeit tun sie das
ich habe gestern erkannt dass der
Jahrgang ein hohes Selbstbewusstsein hat
das ist gut so
selbstbewusstes Auftreten ist wichtig
aber bitte nicht überhebliches
und ich weiß auch dass ich Sie richtig
verstanden habe mit diesem
Selbstbewusstsein sind Sie in der Lage
Ihre Frau und ihren Mann zu stellen und
zu stehen
aber
betrachten sie ihren Dienst immer mit
der erforderlichen Demut und auch mit
der erforderlichen Dankbarkeit
das wichtigste insbesondere für sie als
junge Offiziere ist Menschenführung
das macht das fachliche Wissen ist
sowieso vorausgesetzt aber die Art und
Weise wie sie mit den ihnen anvertrauten
Menschen Soldatinnen Soldaten umgehen
ist entscheidend
denn eines ist auch klar zu sagen die
beste materielle Ausstattung wird uns
nicht helfen wenn wir nicht die
richtigen Menschen haben die diese
entsprechend bedienen können
in diesem Sinne wünsche ich Ihnen
für den weiteren militärischen Lebensweg
und den milizoffizieren auch
insbesondere für ihren zivilen Lebensweg
alles Gute es lebe der Jahrgang Freiherr
von Wolfsberg es lebe die Theresianische
Militärakademie es lebe das
österreichische Bundesheer
[Applaus]